würde mir das verhalten von google wave
fertiger volker hat im moment ganz nicht
mit der biografie familie und mascus
umgesetzt wurde gründer ist für tesla
eine vision hat ihnen etwa wenn man noch
in gott für das ist aber wirklich ganz
auf das arschloch zu der branchen im
umfeld steve jobs gab es in reihen der
ex ist dann aber gleich ganz alleine
sterben auch ab wo man sich dann fragt
hat sich das dort sachlich grund für die
menschen oder ist und glieder schafft so
viel wert dass alles andere rund um man
vergisst es passt dass bc sich
gesellschaft vom egoismus und im moment
wird egoismus serie trägt das politisch
sektors kulturelle bieten elon musk
werde thurk und werde zu ganz große
vision herren erklärt ich persönlich
muss wie die entscheidung von ganz
kleinen kreis und durch war immer wieder
fehler
nach den auftritten verdienen normaler
sport musik frauen in dem monat und
vernachlässigten führen aber ich meine
freundin oder mini familien und freunde
und ich versuchte dem regen wir
mittelweg zu finden das ist wahnsinnig
schwierig am anfang muss die vorgabe wie
jeder für sich selber beantworten
vereinbarkeit wo erfolg und wirkliche
für sie in dieser liga schafft mit dem
soziale ist wahnsinnig schwierig